[Musik]
kein frieden ohne gerechtigkeit ruft
kommt die nicht wollen sie das alte
amerika abschaffen
seit george iv leute unter dem knie
eines heißen polizisten erstickte
marschieren sie jeden zweiten tag durch
washington die konsolen citizens ein
neuer zusammenschluss von 25 aktivisten
stopp am weißen haus bei einer der
gründer erklärt die ursprüngliche idee
kampf gegen weiße polizeigewalt die
realität in diesem land macht uns angst
wir sind es leid immer wieder
unschuldige söhne und töchter unseres
landes die aussehen wie ich als märtyrer
betrauern zu müssen
doch jetzt geht es ihnen um mehr in
einem zehn punkte katalog fordern sie
eine reform von polizei justiz und
regierung der grundsatz alle menschen
sind gleich soll endlich gelten
wir verlangen ein neues amerika amerika
war nie für uns schwarze
wir waren schließlich mal besitz wir
wollen alles neu einen neuen obersten
gerichtshof einen neuen senat das alles
in amerika neu entworfen wird mit uns
dabei im blick ankunft am lincoln
memorial wo martin luther king seine
berühmte rede hielt eine
führungspersönlichkeit wie ihn brauchen
sie nicht sagen sie die energie jedes
einzelnen sei stark genug
schließlich trifft die korona pandemie
die schwarzen besonders stark die wut
sei groß
all diese jungen leute haben zwei
pandemien durch des rassismus und die
mit dem wir sie ringen mit so vielen com
jetzt sind sie die bewegung sie brauchen
sit-in vor dem büro von washingtons
bürgermeisterin die freedom fighters
eine neue initiative aus studenten die
nun konkret was bewirken wollen
es läuft eine anhörung zum budget der
polizei
die übertragen sie nach draußen die fand
the police der polizei gelder wegnehmen
wollen auch philomena und jacqueline die
beiden gründerinnen der initiative eine
initiative von so vielen im land weiß
kämpfen für schwarze das ist neu ich
erlebe rassismus an der seite meiner
schwarzen kommilitoninnen und freunden
ist das ist meine aufgabe
gott hat mich auf die erde gebracht um
anderen weißen menschen zu erklären wenn
es um gerechtigkeit geht dann sollten
nicht nur schwarze für schwarze kämpfen
wir brauchen alle menschen ist im kampf
für die schwarzen philomena kämpft mit
dem freedom fighters und jacqueline an
ihrer seite
doch sie ist erschöpft und müde vom
jahrelangen ringen um anerkennung als
vollwertiger mensch extremem und ich
hasse es bei der hand auszustrecken zum
anderen unterstützen sie bitten
eigentlich sollten sie das als menschen
von selber wollen und wir sind doch
menschen wie atmen leben lieben genauso
wir sollten euch nicht erst von unseren
schmerz überzeugen müssen damit ihr
kapiert wie schrecklich dieser mann ist
über all die jahre anfühlt an der seite
von schwarzen hat auch schon mal holland
gekämpft damals in den 1960 er jahren
mit schwarzem kommilitonen setzte sie
sich in restaurants die nur für weiße
ware
sie hatten erfolg mit dem
bürgerrechtsgesetz wurde die
rassentrennung aufgehoben
die revolution ist nicht vorbei meine
generation hat die rassentrennung
bekämpft aber die grundlage auf die
trennung gebaut war ist rassismus und
der ist immer noch felsenfest da die
jüngere generation von heute muss also
mit der spitzhacke dieses fundament von
rassismus aufbricht oft begegnete den
aktivisten von damals purer hass hier
werden sie mit senf und ketchup
überschüttet jones rat an die jungen
leute von heute organisiert euch
marschieren reicht nicht
damals wollten wir das gesetz verändern
heute geht es um die haltung und die
handlungen der menschen
es scheint dass das gesetz der leichtere
teil war schwarze leben zählen rufen sie
auch in los angeles proteste an ost- und
westküste in städten auf dem land
wochenlang das hat es bislang nicht
gegeben dass proteste immer noch nötig
sind macht ihn traurig mag crack das
foto auf seinem shirt zeigt ihn als
demonstrant von 1992 schließt er die
augen sieht er einen mühsamen weg einen
weg der längst noch nicht zu ende ist
der kampf geht weiter
martin luther king und malcolm exam den
fackel stadt weitergereicht an mich nun
geht er an diese generation los angeles
1991 der afro amerikaner rodney king
wird von polizisten zusammengeschlagen
nach ihrem freispruch ein jahr später
entlädt sich wut in gewalt beim sturm
auf das polizeiquartier ist marc reck
ganz vorn dabei
heute ist er mit einem der polizisten
von damals befreundet mit sam
damals stand der den demonstranten
gegenüber heute hält dazu ihnen heute
setzen beide darauf dass sich etwas
ändert
damals war der so viel wut so viel mist
kommunikation freute es dass ein
friedlicher protest
es gibt mir das gefühl dass es eine
chance gibt dass wir zusammenkommen
können auch wenn wir politiker haben die
uns wieder in zwei lager speisen ein
wandgemälde in los angeles erinnert an
mag und an 1992 den demonstranten von
heute zollt er respekt sie hätten
bereits viel bewegt
die kids von heute 30 jahre und jünger
sind da draußen und kämpfen
sie haben es geschafft dem präsidenten
den mächtigsten mann der welt in den
bunker zu schicken
unglaublich kämpft weiter keine
gerechtigkeit kein frieden der
schlachtruf gilt nach wie vor
marx hofft dass aus den protesten von
heute eine nachhaltige bewegung wird
amerika steht im wahljahr am scheideweg